le nouveau service interdépartemental de
l'adoption des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine existe depuis le 1er
janvier 2017
grâce à cette mutualisation de
compétences il est devenu le service
d'adoption le plus grand de france car
il concerne potentiellement 3 millions
d'habitants nos deux départements ont
fusionné leur service adoption et
c'était l'occasion de faire passer un
message à ce service de l'adoption qui
est désormais le plus grand de france
je pense qu'il peut participer à faire
évoluer la législation
donc on voit bien qu'elle est tout à
fait adapté et donc le fait d'être le
plus rampe permettent d'être le plus
innovant et que cette innovation se
diffuse sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
l'adoption dans les deux départements
représentent 300 demandes en 2016
184 dans les hauts-de-seine et 116 dans
les yvelines
des demandes qui engendre souvent une
procédure de plus de neuf mois
avec ce service le président du conseil
départemental des hauts-de-seine patrick
devedjian souhaite v s'amplifier dans le
processus d'adoption ce que l'on peut
déplorer
c'est là sur administration et la
déshumanisation
dans l'adoption il ya juste un mot dont
on n'entend jamais parler et qui le mot
essentiel c'est le mot amour dans la
démarche
ça c'est presque un conte venant d'en
parler pour l'année 2010 est le nouveau
service d'adoption dispose d'un budget
de 100 2000 euros pour simplifier vos
démarches l'organisme a mis en place le
site questions de famille